what's up guys we're going to show you
how you can use your iphone as your
webcam on your macbook pro it's part of
the new uh software updates in mac os
ventura and also ios 16. the phone and
the laptop will seamlessly connect
together when you're in the lock screen
on your phone and then voila you now
have your phone as a webcam we have the
belkin clip here it's a pre-production
unit here so we're using that to hold
the phone on place on the macbook pro
and i'm now looking at myself with a
beautiful
camera system gone are those 720 days
i've now got the iphone's camera and
it's awesome i got center stage i've got
portrait i got studio lighting and i got
desk view desk view is fantastic you can
show things on your desk think of the
opportunities you could do with
continuity camera it doesn't have to be
on the desk imagine
in your room it's above but if you're in
a zoom call or google meets meeting make
sure you're wearing pants because
otherwise you accidentally click it and
you're wearing underwear everyone's
gonna see